the leading coefficient test does it is
it determines what the end behavior is
when we talk about end behavior mmm
she's me we talk about whether the graph
is going up to the right down to the
right so that's the right end of the
graph or up to the left or down to the
left that's the left end of the graph so
that's the leading coefficient again
tells us about the end behavior so the
leading coefficients the one that leads
off the polynomial when it's written in
standard form which is the descending
order of the degrees of the terms so
forth degrees second degree constant
it's going in descending order leading
coefficients to one again that's in
front and if it's negative what that
tells you is that as X gets larger and
larger
okay so X ten hundred thousand it's
going towards positive infinity what's
gonna happen is this term is going to be
the most influential term it's going to
grow faster than these two terms which
means that as X gets larger and larger
this is gonna become a larger and larger
negative number which means that it's
going to be going down to the right if
you want to test it you can just put in
like maybe ten for example ten to the
fourth is ten thousand times negative
two is negative twenty thousand and you
can see that as X is going to the right
this is going down towards a negative
20,000 it's going down down down
whereas here ten is a hundred times
eight that's eight hundred versus
negative would we say twenty thousand
that's a lot larger negative number this
is going to be growing much faster and
it's going to be going towards a
negative infinity now if it's an even
degree so if this highest power term is
even what that tells you is that the end
behavior as you go to the left the graph
is going to have the same end behavior
as the right side of the graph okay so
if it's going down this will be going
down if this was going up then this
would be going out so this one's going
down this one will be the same direction
and if again if you want to test it out
just to prove it to yourself pick a
value of x like say for example negative
ten negative 10 to the fourth power is
take positive ten thousand because a
negative to an even power is positive
but then times negative two makes us a
negative 20,000 you can see this is
decrease
it's becoming a very large negative
number now what happens in between these
two end behaviors that's what we talked
about in another video with the finding
the zeros that's where it crosses the
x-axis it's gonna cross and it's you're
gonna find some additional points to get
a better shape for your graph a better
sketch but for this video we're just
trying to analyze you know what's
happening to the right and to the left
okay so let's go over to the next one
here this one notice the leading
coefficients positive so that means as x
increases this is going to go up to the
right it's an even degree again
second-degree is even so that means it's
going to go up to the left this one over
here we've got a leading coefficient
that's positive so that means it's going
to go up to the right and it's an odd
degree so odd I mean you think of odd
degree think of it's going the opposite
direction so that means it's going to be
going down to the left and then over
here leading coefficients negative down
to the right so the leading coefficient
is always telling you about the right
end behavior and then the degree is
telling you about what happens to the
left if it's an odd degree it's going to
go the opposite direction